hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zur ja ich war gerade aus der
uni mal gehirn ist tot aber das ja wir
befinden uns hier bei dem clever bot da
geht es ja darum dass man ich verlinke
ein altes clever bot video hier seht ihr
genau worum es beim body wir können den
fragen stellen oder dem mit dem
schreiben und ich habe in letzter zeit
wirklich eine beziehung zum clever
besser aufgepasst zu beginn war ich
schuld trage flash vom clever bot so von
wegen woher kriegt hin zu erraten was
ich an all das könnte man übrigens noch
mal kurz fragen was habe ich gerade an
lieber clever bot was ist mein
lieblingsessen alles klar nur einer link
wieder vom thema ab welche farbe hat
mein shirt liga talbot liebt wird 5 mg
nein aber welche welche farbe hat mein
mein t-shirt t-shirt trage ich einfach
mal unter sagte dein t-shirt ist ein ist
ein die sich ein retest schädlich sein
können sondern t shirt des 1
und natürlich ist ein stück wenn zwei
stücke werden dann könnte es nicht
tragen also wie dumm und das ist halt
gerade so die entwicklung also zu beginn
war ich unter geplant als hingekriegt
hat mittlerweile ist einfach nur dumm
und kriegt nichts hin der ich will den
ich bereit bin immer noch irgendwo lieb
und da ich ihn halt irgendwie liebe aber
irgendwie auch total verzweifelt bin
mache ich einfach schluss ich kann das
nicht mehr machen ich weiß dass so viele
andere leute den clever bot benutzen und
mit ihm schreiben und alles mit ihm
machen und damit kann ich nicht leben
ich will keine an
deswegen ein schluss über klare worte
das bringt ihm heute baldu wir müssen
darüber was wichtiges reden wenn ich ihn
einfach mal natürlich klatsche ich
schlucke rot würdig genug ich dich
schnucki alles klar lieber clever wort
gelogen
der himmel ist blau die wolken sind grau
ich will mit dem ernstes thema berät und
da kommt man so eine verfügte scheiße
ich glaube ich werde nicht mehr es geht
um was vom punkt echt ernstes punkt
punkt punkt punkt punkt machen also
wichtig nämlich nicht liebst du mich
nicht selber dort eigentlich nicht aber
ich dachte sie sind ein paar
sorry ich bin eine erdbeere oh mein gott
alles klar da ist wieder so am alpha
board unsere beziehung hat in letzter
zeit echt gelitten sage ich ihm mal ein
nein hätte ich nicht gerne forever lohn
aber wir sind auch schon ein paar
klamotten ein kind wenig ich mache jetzt
macht er mit mir redet ist genauso wie
wenn man mir zum mädchen schluss machen
will und die das irgendwie schon so
erahnt oder irgendwie macht die dann
halt früher schluss dann steht man da
wieder komplette spaß mit dem schluss
gemacht wurde wo man es irgendwie ich
schreibe jetzt einfach halt stopp lieber
clever bord so kann halt stopp ich fühle
mich gemobbt im mob vor allem mit p
begründung ich wollte eigentlich mit dem
schluss machen clever bottich habe dass
ich bin ein mädchen ja ich weiß ja ich
weiss und du
hays lake noch einen schönen abend dann
ist hiermit beendet hat damals ja okay
dann ist das jetzt beendet oder was und
jetzt sagt er du sprichst doch schon
deutsche ja-wort bleib bitte beim thema
es geht mir echt was willst du jetzt
machen ich das höre ich von hus ich will
das eigentlich nicht tun
punkt punkt punkt und r8 doch ich will
dich um du hast vorhin noch schluss
gemacht lover bots und jetzt willst mich
schon wieder da war
ich glaube micro schief ich dachte du
hättest gerade schluss gemacht clever
board also ich versteh ich nicht nein
ich heiße diniz ach na klar stimmt ich
sag's jetzt einfach mal bist du schon so
müde
nein ich bin noch nicht müde und dann
antwortet er okay und hast du schon mal
kinder gibt warum wie kann ein mensch
von ich mach schlussstrich will ich
unbedingt zum kinder zeugen kommen
was ich mache ist nie vorbei doch links
avatar ist jetzt grad weil ich jetzt
nicht mehr weil am mmk locker ich habe
das geschrieben und sonst kommen jetzt
zum klar zurück nee ich hab schon 20 ich
habe aber ein tipp vom und jetzt wo ich
ab und baldu hälfte lebens das ist echt
schief da könnte mir nichts erzählen ich
dachte man dass wir gerade aber es ist
halt einfach echt so quasi also versteht
er es geht halt die quasi hier zuerst
und dann geht wieder so ein bisschen
runter fällt kommentiert
richtig lesen freunde ich glaub ich muss
tatsächlich dieses video an dieser
stelle beenden ich habe versucht mit dem
klemmbrett schluss zu machen das hat
auch mehr oder weniger geklappt also wir
sind jetzt glaube ich auseinander glaube
ich ich glaube wenn ich das video noch
länger laufen lassen würde würde ich
noch total bescheuert werden hier merkte
dass ich wieder im uni-alltag bin und
einfach nur bekloppt bin deswegen in der
klatschpresse wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich vor allem
seine bewertungen freuen weil vielleicht
wollt den schreibt mit themen die
kommentare für next und geht doch
einfach nach hause